oh good welcome I mean it's beautiful
though you did that thing yes how does
this feel you had to wear a really big
dress because you wanted you needed some
you know you're all alone tonight that
way like so fabulous thank you I just
thought it was beautiful
how do you feel it's out in the world
videos are out yeah I'm super excited I
have a single coming out on the 24th of
October some citations I'm really
excited about it I mean how have you
you've taken your time on this so what
is your sound explain to the fans like
what you're going for because everyone
you know it has a lot of expectations
which is aptly titled yeah aptly titled
I felt like so as well but yeah I mean
I've just kind of been exploring I'm
letting it be as organic as possible
I've been writing um you know a lot and
just kind of exploring myself and you
know with each song it kind of has a new
life so sometimes I'm creating it from
scratch so it all depends I'm
gravitating a lot towards guitar a lot
towards like more like alternatives mix
with like R&B sounds so it's kind of
like in that room but I'm not really a
hundred percent set on any tomia records
done I mean it's in the works it's in
the works it's not done at all this year
you think no probably not probably not
probably next year yeah and what is it
like for you to be here at you know the
AMA is where it is girl power night I
mean from Taylor to Jennifer Lopez -
cardi B - Mariah I mean the icons are
out tonight icons are out sometimes I
don't but like you're also part of that
group you know what I mean you're like
here you're you guys have made history
so what is it like to be a woman in
music right now it's incredible it's
music I feel like a lot of women are
really connecting with themselves and
expressing themselves and kind of just
giving their all in music I just saw
duas red carpet and she looks amazing
talk about the fashion tell me about
that thank you okay yeah this is Pamela
Roland you thank you yes it's like goth
fairy princess
[Music]